[Music]
it's 2016 allowed house became one of
the most popular Nickelodeon shows ever
featuring characters with strong
personalities and interesting dynamics
the fans of the show started discussing
different conspiracy theories some of
them are interesting and others are
incredibly dark stay tuned to hear the
shocking theory about the loud house
creator that's actually real give this
video a thumbs up and hit the subscribe
button if you love the loud house now
let's check out 10 the loud house
conspiracy theories Lin is a transgender
girl we all know the loud house is a
pretty progressive cartoon that even
features a biracial gay couple so could
this theory really be that off lin loud
is a transgender girl let's start with a
very simple observation her dad is lin
loud senior in some cases the firstborn
son is usually considered the junior of
the family in this case it would be
Lincoln
so how come Lin was the one that got her
father's name and not Lincoln could it
be that she was actually the firstborn
son and in the episode where Lincoln
imagined to have 10 brothers instead of
10 sisters
Lin's name was the only one that was
still the same in an episode where
Lincoln hates hand-me-downs Lin gives
him her jockstrap although we know she's
involved in all kinds of sports a
jockstrap is a typical item for men the
loud house team hasn't confirmed whether
this theory is true or not but judging
by some of the progressive characters we
see on the show it's likely that Lin
actually is a transgender and if so the
loud house really is progressive by
choosing not to stereotype Lin's
sexuality or gender Lincoln is an only
child peers out on this one the loud
house revolves around Lincoln which is
largely why there are so many conspiracy
theories around Lincoln's life in the
family we have questions and we want
answers could it be that Lincoln's
actually an only child hear us out on
this one the entire show revolves around
him
typically the middle child doesn't
really have a lot of focus on them sure
he's the only boy in the family but we
also know that he loves to spend a lot
of time
in front of a TV reading books or
playing video games could it be that he
has a huge imagination and he's actually
an only child some of the fans think
that he's imagining living in a large
family like this and because kids at
school always talk about siblings he
imagines what it's like to have a lot of
sisters we also know he cares about his
sisters a lot more than his parents do
he seems to have a lot of responsibility
when it comes to settling fights and
caring for younger siblings especially
for a middle child could it be that he's
actually an only child he's just
imagining what it would be like to have
a large family
smart a lot of fan conspiracy theories
revolve around certain characters but
this one is all about a specific episode
called butterfly effects many of our
theories single out Lincoln's
personality as something negative so
this theory is definitely refreshing in
butterfly effects Lincoln messes up
Lisa's experiment which sets up a chain
reaction of some of the worst moments on
the show it turns out that Lincoln was
imagining all these things as a
worst-case scenario but some of the
things he imagined were pretty clever
for eleven-year-old boy when Linney
becomes more intelligent she's able to
talk about some pretty impressive math
stuff she even solves a math equation
she'd never be able to do otherwise on
top of that she disproves Newton's law
of physics well since the seams turned
out to be imagined by Lincoln could it
be that he's in fact so clever he was
able to predict exactly what Lenny would
say if Lincoln's able to point out
Lisa's math equation mistakes
he's definitely holding back but this
episode brings us to Lincoln slightly
anxious mind personality disorder let's
talk about Lincoln's possible
personality disorder as the only boy in
the family it's of course very easy to
be easily irritable in the hot-headed
but one deviantART user pointed out that
Lincoln could have a personality
disorder borderline personality disorder
symptoms include emotional instability
insecurity antisocial behavior risky
behavior and more we all know these
symptoms largely fit Lincoln's
personality he's also selfish at times
even though he of course takes care of
his family more than his parents we've
also seen Lincoln have a lot of mood
swings and he
easily irritated at everyone around him
including video games even though he
goes by day by day he seems to be
extremely temperamental at the same time
he sometimes doesn't take things
seriously
of course the deviantART user argues
that it's just a cartoon and that it's
probably not as serious what do you
think stay tuned for more shocking
theories about Lincoln's that totally
makes sense neglecting children you
probably noticed that the loud parents
are never around they leave Lincoln and
the kids to take care of themselves this
includes going wherever they want
without adult supervision and leaving
them alone with the eleven month old
baby Lily it's probably not the smartest
choice especially since the kids always
get in some kind of a mess we've rarely
seen them actually leave the house to go
to work and there are two possible
theories behind their absence it could
be that the parents are just constantly
at work to make their ends meet or that
they simply don't care that much about
the kids and are neglecting them the
kids take care of themselves most of the
time of course the parents make an
appearance here and there but the ones
we remember the most are the times when
they get kicked out of a hotel for going
skinny-dipping in the pool at nighttime
or the time when they both go to an
interview with a babysitting agency and
leave all the kids at home alone they
really seem to let the kids do whatever
they want and they never take any action
after everything goes horribly wrong
what do you think make sure to let us
know in the comments Lincoln was a
disappointment there are so many
theories about Lincoln out there we just
can't get enough of them have you ever
wondered why Lincoln is different from
others
why he's the only one in the loud house
that doesn't have a trophy in the
family's trophy collection and why there
seems to be nothing stereotypical about
him his sisters all have stereotypical
personalities and Lincoln has often been
criticized as to average to be the
center of attention our editor has a
theory that Lincoln's parents are
profoundly disappointed in their only
son which is why he gets the smallest
room that looks as large as Harry
Potter's cupboard under the stairs
but this redditor points out another
interesting fact if you look at the kids
ages you'll notice that there's a slight
gap between Lincoln the middle child and
everyone else there's a three year
difference between Lincoln and
see and a two year difference between
Lincoln and Lynne you redditor claims
that the parents were desperate for a
boy but by the time Lincoln turned 3
they realized he didn't turn out the way
he wanted so they kept on trying year
after year until they finally gave up
considering Lincoln definitely isn't the
smartest could it be that the neglect of
parents don't really care about Lincoln
the redditor claims that the parents
were desperate for a boy but by the time
Lincoln turned 3 they realized he didn't
turn out the way they wanted and so they
kept on trying near after a year until
finally giving up
Lincoln is adopted everyone seemed to
notice that Lincoln is the only boy in
the family and that he's the only one
with white hair if you watched our other
videos on the show do you know that this
is because the characters were
originally rabbits but this theory is so
interesting we have to mention it his
appearance could mean that Lincoln is
actually adopted if the parents tried to
fill the age gap between Lucy and Lynne
the other reason was that Rita and Lynne
senior had so many girls they realized
that the only way they'll get a boy was
to actually adopt this also explains why
Lincoln is so different from the rest of
the family and doesn't really have
stereotypical personality traits like
his sisters could it be that they were
just tired of trying for girls and by
the end they decided to adopt an 11-year
old boy and make him the middle child so
he always has something he can relate to
they're ghosts get ready because our
final two theories are dark make sure
you stay tuned to hear about the Christa
B nose fan theory and allegations but
first let's talk about the fact that a
fan thinks the characters are all ghosts
this deviantART fan states that Lincoln
was a schizophrenic only child that
created 10 sisters for his entertainment
this also ties with the theory that he's
actually an only child except this one
is a bit darker the only way the
characters could actually exist was if
they were dead the fan explains that
Lily died in a miscarriage Lisa died in
the south
experiment Lola ran away to be a
princess and Lana got a disease from the
mud lucy and lynn took their own life
Louann was killed for her jokes
Luna lost her hearing at the concert
lynnie drink poison and preside a car
crash pretty brutal stuff right but the
dark tone of this theory also ties with
another theory that discusses a very
gruesome lost episode called enough is
enough the episode mentions Lincoln
having enough and ending attacking all
his sisters while we're sure that these
are all just innocent theories with no
real evidence you have to see our final
theory which definitely has real
evidence Chris Savino and last but not
least this theory belongs to many news
articles and have covered recent
allegations toward Chris Savino the
creator of the show if you're a hardcore
loud house fan you probably know that
Chris was fired from the show due to
many assault allegations that were
highlighted in light of the 2016
allegations toward Harvey Weinstein and
other big Hollywood businessmen the what
seems to baffle a lot of readers is the
fact that Chris's allegations came from
more than a dozen women and they all
seem to be long-standing could it be
that Nickelodeon hired Chris because
they knew he was going to deliver a hit
show despite the fact his chaotic life
could endanger many animators and others
who worked closely with him we all know
that the movie industry doesn't really
have a clean track record but it looks
like the animation industry is just as
bad you probably know that the loud
house was based on Christina's life
there's no wonder that the show features
so many inappropriate moments
considering his recent allegations
why did Nickelodeon let Chris stay on
the show so long if it seems that most
women
or two of him had a huge problem with
his unprofessional behavior were they
just waiting for him to develop the
story enough what are your thoughts were
you surprised to hear about Chris's
allegations let us know in the comments
and that's it for our video for more
videos like this one check out 10 the
loud house episodes that word for kids
see you next time
[Music]